[Music]
what is poppin
thick fam it is monday morning
monday super bowl hangover holler at
your boy
what's going on dickies stickers thick
gums thickets thick a tears
it is 10 30 a.m your boy got a little
bit of a late start not gonna lie to you
this seven shot espresso needs to kick
in like you wouldn't believe
this is uh 11th show i've done in a row
in uh
seven days so that's cool life is grand
i'm surprised throughout my voice
um
yeah man super bowl week
you got all the fighters in town so we
doubled down on food truck and flashback
fight nights and then you hit the fight
companion saturday with matt matrione
chris d'alia brian callan which is my
favorite show to do
um oh there's matt there we go
one of my favorite favorite people
one of my absolute favorite freaking
people matt matrione we uh
yeah man you got to realize me and matt
go
way back
we go freaking way back and uh
you know i've done a lot of shows i said
this on my instagram i've done a
freaking i said something campaign i've
done a ton of shows with fighters
and it was it's my you'll see man on
food truck and flashback uh fight nights
the new show we're doing
um formerly known as classic fight
companions that's confusing so we
changed the name you know um
you know out of all the fighters i've
ever interviewed out that you know i've
had some great shows some of my favorite
ones you know the one with izzy i
absolutely love chael the shows i do
luke thomas you know
the mma community so great man
none better than matt matrione
you know we started with football
together we had a similar trainer in
lauren landau who's the head strength
conditioning coach for the denver
broncos he got matt and i ready for the
nfl and then when we went into the
ultimate fighter house that was our
connection so we looked out for each
other so if you remember back on that
season 10 ultimate fighter mosfet one of
all time no big deal but uh because of
kimbo not me and matt no one knew who we
were but um if you go back and look at
that season i always looked out for matt
when he had the concussion i was doing
and he was like the snitch right for the
team i was the only one that took care
of him gave him gatorade and stuff like
that because we had a previous uh
connection in lauren landau before so
we've always looked out for each other
and then just similar paths man you talk
about you know football players trying
to shake the
the assumption you know that we're just
these athletic meat heads that are just
trying to make a quick buck in the ufc i
think matt leaned in that little more
than i did my my whole thing was i want
to be taken serious as a martial artist
and matt just let you know he was doing
it for money and something to do and
a pretty damn good career man you know
doing my research
you know i know who matt's fought but i
think when you stop and look at we all
know especially if you're a fan of
fighting you you're familiar with matt
matrione but when you actually look at
his body of work for a guy
that
was always kind of one foot in one foot
out could take it or leave it didn't
know who fedor was for the longest even
when he knocked him out i don't think he
realized what he was up against
um
you know you look at his body of work
and who he's fought and with the little
experience that
both him and i had you know it's pretty
crazy man pretty crazy you know he's
fought some you know check congo roy
nelson brennan trump uh derrick lewis
gabriel gonzaga ben rothwell travis
brown
fedor roy nelson he beat roy uh a lot
ryan bader
kirtanov you know um just you know he's
[ __ ] the who's who in the game man
and talking about a guy who
not really passionate about fighting
just a freak athlete great footwork
and i always thought um you know we
talked about this in companion i always
thought matt was going to be
you know i thought matt was going to
turn into kind of like a bisping guy as
far as a guy who had a great career
obviously
nowhere near the career bisping hedge
i'm not a you know face of european
mixed martial arts and they haven't had
one since to be honest
they've tried but guys just keep
dropping the
the ball for lack of a better metaphor
especially when it comes to euro
but they've tried but there's just never
been another michael bisping so
but my comparison there is you know
bisping took his career you know world
champion and had some phenol fights hall
of famer first ballot hall of famer
and then parlayed that into you know his
career as an analyst and he's obviously
a huge
uh huge in the space of youtube and he's
one of you know there's only about six
of us uh you know who dropped some facts
when it comes to fighting stuff like
that and speaks from his heart even
though he works for mickey mouse
so
you know i thought
mitchell would have a similar career
path
and then you got to realize as smart as
matt is even those nicknames meathead
as smart as matt is he has all the
charisma in the world and i you know i
referred to him as batty off uh fern
gully i'm telling you if you look up
clips on youtube it's matt matrione to a
[ __ ] t
he is batty he's all over the place just
the way he's wired
it's not you know drugs or anything like
that it's just matt matrion you know
maybe his mama's titty milk or whatever
just made his brain a little different
he's wired a little different and he's
one of the most unique characters on the
frickin planet
so i thought he would parlay that into a
really successful
mma media career
and then you forget oh he doesn't care
about mma he doesn't care about fighting
so you know he's doing his thing now and
he fought that trailer boxing fight
again
just for the money
you'll hear about the m why he did it on
food truck in the flashback fight nights
and i get it i get it you know he has a
wife now and he has three babies when i
say babies one's 16.
that was the thing i said on companion
too the the one thing that i admire most
about matt even before i before i had
kids you know i've always wanted to be a
dad i've always pride myself on
being a great dad and i will always
remember matt even when the ultimate
fighter house when his i think his kid
you know his kids were young i think he
had like a
two week old and then like a
four-year-old or some [ __ ] like that he
just kept saying my babies man i miss my
babies he's always put his kids first no
matter what no matter how chaotic his
life was matt always doubled down on his
kids which make me made me love matt
even more
it's long story short i love matt
matrion we're gonna do more work
together you know we did the
we spit ball some ideas about you know
he wants to do a cooking show he's
really into barbecue and stuff like that
and he has all these connections i think
there's something there definitely
there's something there
um that could be dope i'll be completely
down for that and i just i talked to him
this morning i said we just got to do
more together man like i think i haven't
seen matin
when he fought theodore which i think
2018 maybe when i worked for bellator
at mass square garden when he beat
fedors by the way
so that's the last time i saw matrion
that is
five years ago
before that i didn't see him so probably
another five years so i've seen him
twice in 10 years can't be that good of
friends but you know how it is when you
you know i think because me and matt are
similar in a lot of ways when we meet up
it's not you know you have those friends
where if you don't check in with him
it's always awkward and then you got to
get through that awkward phase like oh
what's going on man holy kid oh god dude
this time my me my friends talk you
gotta get that weird like awkward
transition
catching up
matt's one of those guys
very rare in my life one of those guys
you just don't have to worry about and
thank god
thank freaking god but
that food truck will drop soon that
flashback fight night will drop soon a
little awkward again i don't pick the
fights my team here pick the fights we
kick off that flashback fight night with
me and matt watching uh
let's fight each other so that was
awkward
um but it's just
it's awkward and i'm down to do a
flashback fight night where we watch my
losses that stuff doesn't bother me in
the least bit you know so
i look at like if matt would have won
that fight i'd have no problem with it
because neither of us got hurt thank god
you know he just got choked out but no
one got hurt
no there's no concussion there's no
crazy knockout we talk about going into
the fight and there's a whole backstory
to it and joe silva in the ufc i think
the other reason why matt and i jail
well
is because we're both retired out of the
game we're we're andy dufresne from
shawshank redemption we crawled through
some [ __ ]
we made it on the other side we're in
san mateo or the hell they call it
so we can look back and
matt can speak freely and not worry
about consequences and the ufc coming
after him bellator him after him or
triller coming out he can just
speak his truth and that's what i like
that's what i love man so shout out to
matt matrion those will drop soon we
also do one michael chandler which we'll
drop um and mike again mike chan is one
of my favorite people too just a
complete savage he talks about his
journey you know his last fight in
bellator and banking himself i'm coming
to the ufc and saying he has to you know
he thought coming to ufc he would regret
it for the rest of his life we didn't
come to ufc and just talked about that
whole transition and also his fights
but again with with uh chandler you know
in the ufc he is what is he he's uh one
and two one and three
i think he's one and two so you do
flashback fight nights
you know we watched one bellator won his
last fight with uh benson henderson
which was a critical moment in his life
yeah he's one and two but really that
justin gates you fight and that's that's
not gonna hurt you as far as the q goes
so
you know he's he's one and two but
really he's
it's
one and one and a big one that's a loss
you know what i'm saying so his career
is going pretty damn good in the ufc but
um
you know we watched the the
benson henderson fight because it was a
big one and then we go into his ufc
fights and you know you we watch the
hooker fight which is a great night for
him and then we watch the uh
the charles olavera fight you gotta
watch some losses man because again it's
not the
flash flashback fight night only win
show it's it's it's about historic
moments in korean
you know in fighting some of your
biggest moments that make or break your
entire career some of your losses how
you're defining your losses and i think
that's the biggest takeaway
with uh chandler and he's just a great
dude man great dude um last night
so did the companion on uh
friday i'm sorry it was on saturday for
ufc 271 great card his thing about
companions is we're drinking and it's
you know brian and chris through my best
friends and mr owns one of my best
friends
so we pay attention to the fights but
it's really the dudes hanging out man so
i almost need to just
reserve myself from giving my opinion
when there's a decision
because i i see like certain moments but
as far as like watching it i mean i
still do a better job than the referees
and the judges in there but still
it's just
i should really hold off on making a
prediction because i man i and
chris pride doing an uh oops grenade
joke during the key transition and you
know and then all i see is robert
whittaker shooting for takedown so
i'll look at chin like hey jin who won
china i'm [ __ ] nice i'm with you guys
dude i'm working i don't what do i look
like man so
you know i need to hold off on giving my
uh if it goes this close to soon given
my opinion because
from the key moments i saw and this is
obviously the
the hot topic in mixed martial arts
right now the decision for izzy and
robert whittaker
so whenever we do a uh fight campaign
every every single time sunday morning i
re-watch the card only the main card i'm
not gonna lie to you i re-watch the main
card because usually i can watch all the
early prelims and prelims
sober and focused at home my kids might
be running around causing ruckus but i
can pay attention for the most part
the main card i always have to watch the
first thing i do wake up sunday morning
at six am and i go to uh the espn plus
and then i go through all the main
events because usually my girl and her
family are watching so you know you can
watch because you already bought it
thank god i don't buy it twice or really
three times i have to buy it here buy
from my girl and then if i go watch a
sunday morning i'll have to rebuy it
they let you have it i guess
so even my son's seen the last major
pay-per-views for i don't know how long
i'll be doing campaign now about six
months
so you sit down and watch it with me but
uh
yeah i go through all of them man and it
was uh especially the the main card was
a really good card man it was overall
just a great night great night in
houston obviously there's a little bit
of
drama going into it right no joe rogan
um
no joe rogan which uh
again i said something companion do i
know exactly what happened sure do is it
my story to tell nope but when it comes
out you're gonna love joe rogan every
even more for missing that one i'll say
that i'll say that men but uh and you
also love dana white even more i will
never ever
talk [ __ ] about dana white again
after hearing you know him going to bat
for his guys he's just a real one he's a
real one he might not like me but i like
him
that's how it goes you know we got the
crushing the girl in high school and
she's just not having it man that's
what's going on here
i'm the fat kid at the lunch table and
the hot chicks there and she's not
feeling me that's all right guys yeah
you can still have that crush
you i don't need love back
but uh yeah bottom line no joe rogan
michael bisping fills in
there can be a guy better for the job
you know um tough tough position i think
even if i'm i think michael bisping is
getting some criticism for being biased
in the fight um
which i definitely have my thoughts on
that i think no matter
how well bisping did he was gonna get
criticized because
whenever there's change whatever it is
listen the shows i run here whenever
there's even a slight change people hate
changement if you're expecting one thing
and you're used to this one thing
um and that one thing is the greatest
ever do it as far as joe rogan john eck
in dc i think there's literally that is
the best commentary team of all time
of absolute all-time there's no one
better
so for bisping to be the guy that
replaced him and obviously forbids me
it's a great opportunity and biswing's
very
uh capable of filling those shoes and uh
he's also a great commentator um i think
no matter what i don't know how bisman
feels about social media and criticism
hopefully doesn't listen to it um but he
was going to get [ __ ] no matter what
because you're filling in for literally
the most famous man
of all time in the ufc joe rogan and he
has a a ton of support and they'll take
their anger out on the guy who has
nothing this means like yeah what yeah
i'll do it you got it i'm playing the we
flew out that night
that's not a bisping thing that's a you
know mickey mouse ufc thing
so you know i i when i saw biswing flat
i'm like oh he's gonna take some flack
for it no matter what he no matter how
he doesn't take some flack for it
so bismuth tweeted this lots of people
saying that bias commentary that's crazy
i caught like i saw it big open round
for izzy then real close rounds after
that
but is he winning most five
five was rob's best round two probably
went tim also close fight very technical
well done to both couldn't agree most we
couldn't agree more with uh michael
bisping um
again when i when i was watching it
i uh
i was drinking a ton of whiskey and uh
and laughing with my friends but i would
see
whitaker you know engage in the takedown
stuff like that
we knew he was going to do more
takedowns and i also
you know i don't think it's i'm saying
anything that reinvents the wheel here
but
also
robert whittaker it's the best version
of him and we knew he was going to try
to grapple more especially with his
background his wrestling background and
then also going off the blueprint of yon
at 205 against izzy if you can take izzy
down in the middle of octagon he can't
do who i think he's probably the best of
all time his cage defense him or camaro
but they're up there you know what i'm
saying but as far as izzy not being a
wrestler his
if you're gonna try and take him down
against the cage it ain't happening i
think the only guy can do that's
probably a bigger guy like a yon
or or even a a khabib you're talking
about the greats be able to take him
down but outside that there ain't nobody
85 taking the man down against the cage
it ain't happening
so
i do think robert whitaker had a a
better game plan going into this one
but he didn't go for broke right he was
very tentative waited needed izzy to
commit
and uh
you know you're gonna
in order to beat izzy it's not gonna be
exciting
it's just not if you're gonna want to
beat him
you know it's gonna be a slower you
gotta be willing to deal with the
backlash from the fans and especially in
person you can get booed
you're not gonna get into the shootout
with izzy and walk away the winner it's
not gonna happen the only way is he is
gonna lose is probably a boring decision
man and you're gonna have to grapple him
make it net you know you don't get a
[ __ ] fight with him a phone booth fight
you're not gonna win that either so
you're gonna have to grapple him make it
boring control
you land some shots you're not gonna
finish him you're just not you're not
gonna land some huge shot he's too good
of a striker he's too long for the
division so it's just not gonna happen
and dc and i talked about this yesterday
i think he talked about it on the super
bowl uh companion we did which was
just so you guys know the way that works
that was a
money line uh mike tyson production so
my team didn't shoot that that was a uh
the mauka team shot that
it's the most hollywood thing i've ever
done i've been in hollywood for quite
some time now 10 years
it's the most hollywood thing i've ever
seen
so just a little background on that i
get a call i don't know two weeks ago
hey we want you to host this super bowl
party like i like parties i like hosting
you know yep so you're going to watch
super it's going to be the companion
show they want to do a companion show
that you do and in my head whenever
people outside of our world
go hey what we want you to do a
companion show
well here's the thing that's where
hollywood just gets it wrong and i'm
saying they did this but they tried
their best hollywood goes oh that's a
successful model
uh for
you know guys comics hanging out and
watching something and people are
watching them and listening they're
commentating and it does great views
after the fact too we can do that we can
recreate that but what they don't get is
originally the fight companion was four
best friends and there's chemistry and
we're friends and we know each other and
you know we elevate each other and if
someone's doing a bit you play off of it
no one's trying to steal the show
there's no agenda it's for friends
hanging out having fun if you want to
engage and watch the fight and talk
about it you do that
or sometimes you know when we do it with
joe rogan eddie bravo brian count myself
we talk about octopuses for an hour
that's the fight companion man there's
no agenda there's no script it's uh you
know
pretty pretty ruthless and you know when
you talk about whatever see so when
hollywood gets involved in the you have
a producer or something like that you're
not going to get that magic and then
also what they they're missing the point
on is
the reason fight campaign works because
it's four friends you know when you
think about what a cal bass fight
campaign it's so it's never just a
random stranger that's not going to work
they're not going to get the
the vibe of the show so if you think
about calais fight campaign it's brian
callan my absolute best friend for how
long now crystalia right up there this
is my space stays uh chris might be over
talon right now okay do you remember
that dude top ten
top was the top eight and didn't you
have to have the the [ __ ] creator is
your friend was it wasn't it like force
or something tom
wasn't tom half to being like your top
eight or some [ __ ] like that
you know so you know brian up there if
this topic of brian chris theo you know
the rogan all my boys
so but that's why the fight companion
works is because we're all friends and
there's no agenda and there's no
producer in your ear saying make sure
you talk about this make sure you cover
this
so when someone wants to recreate the
kind of the fabric of that show
and this is the call yet two weeks ago
okay so we're thinking companion style
it's you mike tyson i think originally
told me the game and kevin garnett i go
very cool
but if you think this is going to be
similar to what i do there's one slight
problem i don't know them
and they don't know each other really
they might have done shows together like
interview shows or they might have hung
out at a club before but they're not all
good buddies so i have no idea what the
chemistry's gonna be like so you can't
call i wouldn't call companion just call
it the super bowl you know watch party
something like that but to call
companion um
you're missing the the secret sauce man
so you okay cool let us think on it
but we knew tyson was involved and i've
worked with tyson i i love tyson i you
know i think
tyson is a wild card meaning
you don't know what you're gonna get and
i think that's what makes it fun i think
especially for me because i generally
know uh what i'm gonna get i really do i
generally know
kind of is when it's a my fight
commander my shows i typically know
um exactly what i'm gonna get
so
i knew mike tyson was involved and then
um they're looking for another guy and i
said hey
you know if you need a guy that can
speak well and i have a relationship
with and i know i get along with and we
have good chemistry daniel cormier could
be cool he's doing the the pay-per-view
the night before and they said let's
reach out to him and then i text dc i
said do not leave me hanging man i need
you and he answered the call and he came
and he's my absolute you know one of my
favorite people on the freaking planet
and you know he's crushing it man dc is
absolutely crushing it and then when we
got there they go all right there's me a
fourth guy and in my head i'm like here
we go you guys aren't listening your boy
you can't just throw in a guy and then
expect magic maybe it's brandon marshall
well they lucked out on that because me
and brandon have worked together because
i don't know if he's still with showtime
but um bran and i have worked together
multiple times when we were both with
showtime i'm familiar with brandon
marshall
as far as a football player goes he's
the closest thing to
kind of what i do he his pot he has a
huge podcast he speaks his truth he's
just such a you know talking about
maybe i'm biased because he's a bronco
great but i think he's a hall of famer
you know he's a monster first round
draft pick you're the same class as me
but me and brandon have a relationship
so brandon being there i felt uh way
more comfortable
but again so this this thing's going
back to this being the most hollywood
thing i've ever done
it's at lenny kravitz house one of his
houses that he owns it's a 45 million
house that they rented out from lenny
kravitz that picture right there that is
the backyard that's the backyard slash
living room slash living quarters
kitchen so it all opens up and then it's
on in the hills
of hollywood and overlooks all of la
anyone says money by happiness hasn't
seen that view
it's not so's not those
so
you know it's like they mark they like
roped off where we're doing the show
and then behind us is just you know a
freaking nightclub
nightclub thing it's just they have this
crazy sushi being served they have all
the drinks in the world being served and
uh
you know i had anxiety going into it
because again this isn't my thing it's
not my crew it's not my staff i know
dc's there who i know really well me and
b marshall are boys
but we haven't done something like this
and obviously mike tyson's the
kind of the curveball you never know
what you're gonna get and he was great
man
b marshall was drinking the tequila he
was the one who was kind of the the
curveball he wanted he was testing
everyone i mean dude because what they
did is they had guests just sporadically
pop in so you had uh
the nascar drivers bubba wallace and uh
jed bush i think it is popped up
uh you had
you had kyle busch yeah we'll say
jetbuster i think that's a politician
but um yeah you had kyle busch you had
uh these tick tock influencers where i'm
just old man they'd bring these tick
tockers in and i have
no clue who they i'm talking i've never
seen them ever in my life
um
so it was interesting
again it was way different than anything
i do
but i had so much fun because it was the
unknown it was completely different what
i do but brian marshall i'm talking when
we got there he tested mike tyson i
think they should he's trying to box
mike tyson he tried grappling with dc
and boxer dc
uh t teo fomo lopez was there he tried
boxing teo fomo
um dude he tried uh oh so you know you
have guests coming and i can see how my
core my eye people come through the door
because the door was there so i could
see people coming and this guy walks in
and i look at him go look at that i mean
you do not want the problems
so this guy walks in and uh
in my head i'm like that looks like yuri
the the light heavyweight
yeah i'm like that looks like yiri and
then dc i bumped dc because we're on air
so you know you know i go that looks
like yuri dude and dc goes got it does i
go it looks like year if he's a 24-hour
fitness uh trainer because he's written
like these short shorts and a black you
know he looked like uh brad pitt off
that movie where he's a trainer and i
think george clooney's at you know what
i'm talking about
yeah burn after he looks identical to
brad pitt from burn after reading he's
dressed like that i'm like who comes at
a hollywood party dressed like that
and he's
the other thing he's he's not he's tall
but he's real thin dude he's really
that's exactly what that's how you
showed up that's a party minus the
headphones that's exactly how you're
dressed in all black that's his thing
he's not from here he looked phenomenal
his hair's dope
you know but so i'm yeah you know i'm
like yeah you know he looks like a 24
hour fitness yuri version and then dc
like no dude that's him and then i in my
ear like hey uh yuri is joining the show
i'm like oh [ __ ] i go dc that's him man
and he sits down i'm i go dude how much
you i'm talking the boys in shape i
don't know how much do you weigh me is
215.
i said you're a middleweight doug and
dc's like dude if i walked that then i
would the night before the fight i'd
walk at 2 15 to fight 205. he's like you
know it's a struggle for me for that guy
he can just eat normal and do this he's
215. i'm like yo he's a middleweight all
day him versus izzy would be a
phenomenal fight if and this is going
back to izzy
i don't know what's left for is he at
middleweight he's he's too dominant dude
there's not a man on this plant who's
gonna beat him at middleweight
you know i think you all must have
forgot that
how [ __ ] good is he is he he's the
best we have to offer in the ufc it's
him or john jones whatever you want to
do with it but as far as technique-wise
goes dominance-wise there's nobody
better than izzy he's the biggest star
outside conor mcgregor hands down not
even close
but at middleweight there's not a lot
for him right i bet jared cannon there's
next that's a very tough night in the
office for deer cannonaire
he's beat everybody else
i do think you know in a world
that if yuri would have beat glover
texture
and i think this is where izzy's team
made a mistake
in hindsight it's easy to say now
because remember i thought ezra was
going to light yawn up
but john decided to grapple him walking
at 230 240 pounds size made all the
difference it was even technical he just
you know wasn't even that exciting but
was on the feet
izzy lit his ass up right so
i do think if he still wants to pursue
that dream of being the 205 champ
there's a way to do it i do think it's
the best route for izzy
but you got to have the right dance
partner you can't have a guy who's just
going to try and grapple you because
that's that's not what you want to do
and also
if i'm easy i don't want to get the
light heavyweight belt and defend it a
million times because it's all about
matchups so if you look at
if yuri were to win yuri versus izzy's a
phenomenal fight hate to tell you guys
too and i just saw the [ __ ] guy
yesterday so bring the smoke if you want
it your boy's here for it like brisket
sun in dallas
yuri is not that much bigger than is he
i would say izzy's a longer
um
human being he he's just a
you know is he's a big dude man if you
go back to the food truck
you know
um when the first thing i said when i
saw it is he i'm like holy [ __ ] dude
you're babies i'm telling you one thing
i'm too light in the ass way too long
they asked for jon jones i'm not that
small man and this is me like i can put
on weight if i have to
so i think there you see yuri and he's
shredville but he's 215.
he's not that much bigger than izzy so
if he were to become champ i think if
i'm izzy's team we can keep being guys
up at middleweight and set the record
and let's see sure that outfit that's
cool yeah he looks fly he's dude you see
him right oh that's a that's a savage
that's a [ __ ] spartan from the movie
300. if they redo 300 or if they call
like 302 because they've done two now
they do 302. he how's he's not casting
and i have no [ __ ] clue
but um
yuri's not a huge guy that's him there
that's that's in front of the house
that's his outfit that's an outfit yep
that's pretty yeah he's got a personal
train the [ __ ] out of you he's gonna get
you in shape man you can get on the
stairmaster motivate you you know do
some hip thrust and [ __ ] look at his
outfit so yeah yeah i didn't know it was
him you know i don't know
um but the point is if he were to become
dumbledore guy down if there if he's if
he becomes champ oh i didn't know oh no
that's not there different day yeah
that's different
but
if uh yuri becomes champ in uh a world i
think izzy
um
can line up better against yuri because
here he's not going to try and grapple
his ass he's not
so i do think that
if that's what izzy wants to do uh you
should root pretty hard for yeri against
glover
because again it's all about matchups if
izzy wants to take that next step and
become a two division champion which i
think is where the money's at the
stardom's at because him just sitting
around beating up the likes of jared
cannonair or you know these other guys
he's very beat up
doesn't do a lot for me
it does it i don't think he does a lot
for izzy i think you know he can get
anderson silva's
record for most title defenses and if
that's what he wants to do great but as
far as being a straight-up superstar
which is he is now but i'm talking about
putting a goddamn putting some jet fuel
in that pack that he's on
i think the way to do that is to chase
that light heavyweight belt but has to
be the right match up and yeri would be
the right matchup now yuri can grapple
but yuri
is a very
non-traditional
you know wild man he's a wild boy and
he's very very good at it
but again it's about match up so if yuri
doesn't beat glove texera is he just
needs to stay at middleweight because
he's clover if he thought yawn could
grapple
glover can [ __ ] grapple and that
makes no sense rosie to do that again
but if here he wins i would love to see
izzy you know talk some smack and get up
there man i really do think that's the
next evolution of the style bender
because that middleweight you know
are you guys going to give out
let's say what is it a damn near 80
bucks now to watch him versus deer
cannon era rematch against whitaker or
you know some of these other guys
vettori paul costa all that stuff
not really
you know it's going to do well but as
far as like sizzler numbers i think is
he's gonna have to take that chance
again
i'm curious where he's at mentally about
chasing that dragon
and that uh
that 205 light heavyweight belt but if
he already gets it i can
hopefully his team's on the same
parallel thinking thinking all right
yuri is a guy that's going to stand with
us technically we're way better
uh striking but yuri's such a madman and
that goes back to brandon marshall
being seven shots deep with tequila
and harassing mike tyson you see mike
tyson they're
about to light him up then he goes to do
it to yuri and brandon who he is i go
julia's [ __ ] haircut you want to mess
with that guy he is [ __ ] here he's
built like a goddamn mongol dude and
he's like no this guy might hold up and
i told brad i said santiago that's your
next light heavyweight champ
and then you're like you think i win i'm
like i guarantee you one dude which is a
little aggressive i had some drinks okay
but i do think he's one of he he is my
favorite light heavyweight so i want to
see him win so obviously i i'm super
biased but i do think he wins
uh which would be great for izzy um
so you know brand marshall messing with
that guy i was like he's not the one
dude he's just flying knees he's a wild
boy he's not gonna just throw jabs and
[ __ ] at you like that's not the guy to
[ __ ] with
and you can tell i didn't i don't think
they have on video but
yeah but where he comes from i don't
know where he's from i mean not he's not
polish what is he he's is he checked
what is he
is it czech republic
we
found out yeah
yeah i'm telling you man this guy's a
handful
handful
um
and we're going to get him on a food
truck as well oh yeah i talked to i
talked to him this morning actually
bringing him on food truck
so you know um yeah brad marshall was
he was fun he was fun you know those
shows are those shows are crazy man it
was such a good time listen man just
because uh the lockdowns are over people
still shopping online the world has
changed man and online shopping is a
booming and maybe you're part of that
boom and you're selling stuff online and
you got a business online and you're
savvy with it but you need to get your
stuff out man you got to trust people
man you got to trust people because
things are crazy right but it's getting
less crazy but you still got this
business you got to ship stuff and you
got to do it with ship station because
you need ship station as a friend if you
own a business and you're shipping stuff
all right you never have to worry about
shipping again make the switch the
solution that handles all of your
shipping needs quickly it's affordable
it's painless all right ship station is
already trusted by over 100 000
e-commerce sellers including your boy
here keep track of orders from any sales
channel it's easily find the best
shipping carry with the deeply
discounted rates all right so you can
save time by funneling all your orders
in one simple interface no matter what
you're selling man all right manage
every order amazon ebay etsy your own
website like thickboy.com from anywhere
even your phone no more headaches
quit making things difficult use ship
stations save money all right save time
time is money man ship more and less
time with shipstation use my offer code
shob s-e-h-a-u-b to get a 60-day free
trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress-free shipping for your
business just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page type in shobb s-h-a-b ship
station make ship happen listen man this
whole cova thing may probably made you
reconsider your life choices your career
choices you're looking for something man
you want to change your career all right
there's never been a better time to
become a programmer and with code
academy you can learn to code on your
own terms i come from a family of coders
so i recommend this stuff man because
they told me it's pretty good we're
living in a fast changing world one of
the best ways to succeed is learn how to
code man everybody needs coders one of
the best ways to succeed is learn how to
code man everyone needs a coder if you
got code you got a job try codecademy
today and see where coding can take you
whether you're starting from scratch or
looking to advance codecademy can help
you reach your coding goals all right
over 50 million people already know that
codecademy is the best way to learn code
that's because codecademy not only
teaches you job-ready coding skills but
also helps you build unique projects for
your portfolio earn certificates even
prep for technical interviews whatever
it is man learn at your own pace and get
qualified for in-demand jobs choose what
to learn from building basic websites to
ai and everything else you want to do
man all right no matter what your
experience level maybe listen to i know
how to code learn how to code with
codecademy dude all right we got you man
working code in minutes we gotcha learn
coding language including python html
css sql javascript and so much more not
sure where to begin codecademy will
point you in the right direction what
you're looking for we got you get
instant feedback your code is tested as
soon as you submit it so always know if
you're on the right track all right land
your dream job in web development
programming computer science data
science tons more this is the future
baby pick up this skill set man let
codecademy help you out join over 50
million people learn to code with
codecademy see where coding can take you
get 15 off your codecademy pro
membership when you go to
codeacademy.com
use the promo code shop sdhab that's
promo code shobb
codecademy.com to get 50 off codecademy
pro the best way to learn to code
c o d e c a d e m y dot com promo code
is shob but uh back to the main event so
i rewatched it
and dc called me uh sunday morning again
i didn't watch it oh you know what i pro
no not yet when he called me sunday
morning i was getting just getting
through jared cannon here dick brunson
fight
and i was going based off my memory from
the fight campaign when i was about
eight whiskey doubles deep which doesn't
count
and he goes hey am i crazy man you know
the the social media is saying that
robert whittaker won that fight they're
all upset about izzy
and i was like i don't feel stupid you
know because dc works a thing as far as
you know knowing about fighting and i
don't i don't really you know can't
carry um
dc's [ __ ]
water cooler man he you know he's one of
the goats two-time you know world
champion different weight divisions and
olympian and
coaches and he's from aka and best
friends of the cane and the list goes on
and on
and i don't seem stupid i was like i
don't know man i was drinking last night
i thought whitaker did good with the
grappling i'm gonna watch i'll let you
know when i see in person
so i watched it
and
you know i i think you know when people
get really upset and there's you know
there's a uproar on on social media a
lot of it is because
i assume
people thought robert this can be the
best version of robert whitaker and he
put money on it and so when you lose
your money you're pissed right and so so
some of the backlash comes there
but this definitely wasn't like one of
those situations where izzy didn't win
the fight if you go back and watch the
fight first round cersei drops him right
drops him he's pretty wobbled so izzy
clara's day first round second round if
you want to give it to robert whitaker
because he got his back for
10 seconds
you know um okay let's give him the
second round third round and get busy
fourth round get busy then fifth rounds
robert whitaker all day so
uh one clears day five clears day for
robert whittaker it's rounds two three
and four
depending on your judge and how you're
gonna decide the winner of those fights
especially the second round
that would dictate the entire fight
because i i i think you would have a
hard time giving robert whitaker three
rounds i'd love to hear
kind of the explanation of how you give
him three rounds now
those two three and four are close
but if we're going off of what
especially the judge's main criteria
which is damage done
you know izzy definitely did the most
damage if you look at leg kicks and you
look that front lead leg of robert
whittaker he also the head kick he did
block one be blocked with one hand
anyone who's been the game long enough
you know if you block with one hand a
you have a better chance of breaking
your goddamn arm because you need both
to support the kick the force of the
kick
b
if when it's one hand the kick still
rocks your brain so izzy landed i think
two kicks when robert defended with one
hand and then also the body shot hurt
robert whittaker so
if you go through complete damage done
round by round
i don't know how you don't have izzy
still retaining his title i don't get
the uproar again i think a lot of is you
guys lost money bet on robert whittaker
and i get it that's frustrating
but you know to criticize
biz bingo he's biased
dude bisping's there also
bisping was a middleweight champion of
the world
you know so
i know you guys watch a lot of fights
but let's kind of lean into the experts
here bisping knows what the hell he's
doing he's watched a lot more fights
than you also has fought in there at the
highest level and was a world champion
so from bisping's perspective
ndc's for that matter because dc goes
man i don't get it either i thought it
was pretty clear it is the opposite
best seat in the house i mean bisbee had
the exact same thoughts like this is a
clear as day win for izzy he was in my
head when i'm going up to interview him
i'm thinking
did izzy win three rounds of four
definitely didn't lose more than three
right or definitely you know didn't lose
more than two rounds i can see him give
him the fifth maybe the second but even
the seconds little dicey so
in the judge's eyes is it four rounds
crazy or three he's like i knew he won
the fight
so yeah dc backing up what bisping says
obviously bisming's one thing that makes
him great is he's very strong in his
opinions which i love i hate when people
are trying to please both
both sides that never works out for
anybody you got to double down on what
the [ __ ] you think and what you stand
for especially in today's society so i
think bisbee going hard in the paint and
going you know this is claire's day izzy
won this fight four to one
tough to disagree with him but again i
know you guys probably lost money on it
or
you know you love robert whitaker how
can you not the guy's humble even in
defeat
so i get it or maybe you're not an easy
fan so i get it
now that's real and your uproar on
twitter will be it's probably over by
now i bet it was uproar saturday night
sunday morning got a little dicey for a
few guys outside that over now
that's the way the news cycle works so
no one gives a [ __ ] and when it comes
it's very black and white is he won the
fight
so you can cry all you want doesn't
change anything is he won that fight
i have you know i'm fine three to two
i'm fine with three to two
four to one sure if you want you want to
just give robert the the the last round
all right he definitely won that last
round there's an argument there it's
that second round uh depending you know
how you view the fight and then you know
i guess three and four
it'd be easy
you know it'd be easy because
the issue too is you have a lot of the
boxing commissions you know judging
these fights they don't know what the
[ __ ] leg kicks are
but in our sport they're everything and
izzy really lit up that [ __ ] leg and
did the most damage with the kicks
landed the bigger punches
dropped them
um had them wobbled with a head kick but
again if you're a judge and you've never
been in there and you see
whitaker block an izzy head kick with
one hand you think oh he defended that
he did it that actually rocked that man
the force that kick still gets through
with one arm in any time a fighter is
fighting a guy who can kick
in camp you oh the number one thing they
go over is how to block a kick hand up
and then this hand absorbs most of the
shot okay just like this
this still gets through this still lands
and wobbles the [ __ ] brain for a
concussion and that's how robert was
defending the kicks
it's not the ideal way to do it to me
that that's still a head kick still
causes trauma so
again the judges they've never been in
there i i would be willing to imagine no
one's even through a [ __ ] kick so you
want them to grade
izzy out of sonya a former world
champion kickboxer's kicks
okay
i might as well [ __ ] decide who wins
nascar i don't know [ __ ] about nascar
i've never done it i've drove before
never competed
you know what i'm saying so it's it's a
weird correlation that we expect so much
of these judges especially in in an izzy
fight now if it's a grappling boxing
fight yeah that they understand that but
when it comes to kicks and defending
kicks and they think by just blocking
with one hand is good enough it's not
that's still a landed
heavy damaged kick which gives izzy
points in the world of mixed martial
arts so um i have it four to one izzy
i'm fine if you want to go three to two
but izzy definitely won that fight he's
still your your world champion
um
and again i don't know it's no shade on
uh uh ken nair he's a great story right
he's talking about a heavyweight light
heavyweight he's been on a tier at
middleweight you know for derrick bro
derrick brunson had some big shots
really big shots that first round you
know was derek brunson all day and then
obviously the elbows is what put brunson
away and blonde hair brunson away
so he did enough to to get a title shot
you know does canon have the skills to
beat is he again tough night i would
assume is he's a three to one favorite
in that fight so
again as he can keep beating up these
middleweights and
run away with the best middleweight of
all time and you're talking about being
out of guy and ashton silva but but i
really think the future for izzy would
uh
would to be
fight at 205 if fury wins the the light
heavyweight strap and that's your super
fight super super fight that is a hell
of a match up it's exciting it's gonna
be a straight up war on the feet i don't
see a lot of grappling that fight makes
all the sense in the world
again this is all predicate on yerry
winning if he doesn't you're not going
to see as he make the jump because
glover yawn makes no [ __ ] sense where
is he so
your move yerry and i think he would
fancy himself in that fight as well so i
think he would take it um going to the
the co-main event
we knew this wasn't going the disney
yeah it's always uh there's always a lot
of pressure on guys especially when
they're two knockout artists and that's
all they do
you know if you remember francis for
derek lewis how we're filming at the
dick for that fight it was in the worst
fights in ufc heavyweight history
you know i think derek's back was
injured francis was you know dealing
with some issues so you get a terrible
fight
um
so this one kind of lived up to it
because
ty has that thing the the no [ __ ]
gene he has that no matter who he's
fighting
the the only reason you know if you look
at my prediction for this fight
i'm i was rooting for tied to avasta
he's one of my favorite human beings in
the ufc he's exactly what the ufc needs
he's exactly what the ufc needs to grow
you know their exposure and their their
bandwidth into new zealand australia he
represents that community to the fullest
you know you know tai chi of us has
become a professional man i i think
he was the guy that
you know would
drink and do his thing and he's the
chewy guy and he's fun and he'll win one
lose one win three lose one and but as
far as being a professional and a world
class athlete i i don't think he took
himself serious until this fight
until his
almost backs against the wall you
fighting derek close in his hometown
which you know before
derek fought cyril gone he was on defeat
in houston you don't want to fight
derrick lewis and houston he was a
[ __ ] nightmare to find houston
but we know now because derek's team has
said this dirk has said this
derek hates being the main event he
hates dealing with the pressure and the
interviews and all that [ __ ] especially
in his hometown set zero gone fight he
didn't fight like himself he didn't want
to be in there
and i think
similar to this you know in houston now
even though it was on five rounds which
he said was the only issue
i think there's a houston issue now that
he's this famous i think
there's uh
you know there's a traffic jam in his
brain and he fights at home and although
he did land some huge shots on tattoo of
us in that first round which would put
most guys out
um you know taito vasa didn't go away
and i think that
when derek realizes that you know his
one
super power which is landing those
punches whether it's ground and pound or
the right hand on the feet when that
doesn't work he's kind of screwed
and uh it didn't work and he landed
shots that normally put 99 of the world
out and tied to avasa just weathered the
storm they landed that elbow the the ko
walked off home run
and again on companion don't take
anything we say on their serious matt
goes oh i think
derek lewis who matt beep by the way in
the first round knocked him out um i
think he was like derek lewis wanted out
he didn't get knocked out he just wanted
out
and if you just saw it you're like oh
man yeah they didn't look that bad do
they see the replay like oh no no no he
it was lights out
closing time you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying closing time
that that elbow was filthy and now
tattoo vasa
rank top you gotta put on the top five
he's eleven be the number three guy ko
walk off home run so for tai tu avasa
now it's off to the races and luckily
for him he's finally realizing his
potential i think he actually believes
in himself for the first time and now
you have a dangerous dangerous man tied
to avasta i think he's training right
eating right he looks slimmer he looks
more professional he's fighting smarter
he knows he can weather the storm
because he's eating derrick lewis's best
shots and still got the job done so i
feel sorry who has to fight type 2 of us
the next cuz now you're getting tied to
avasa 2.0 you're 2.0 meaning he's
fighting and trading like a professional
now so he's me a tough character to beat
um who's next for him
i assume they put him in the in the top
five you know i don't think he jumps
right to three because you like the the
the ratings the rankings
so you got volkov who he beat i'm sorry
you voke off who derek lewis beat right
um which doesn't always mean that he
would be um tied to avasa but still
i would assume that curtis blades jumps
up to three and you i would assume taito
vasa jumps up to four and derrick lewis
goes to
five does that make sense
i assume derek lewis jumps down two to
two
to
ah man i bet he drops from three
uh
and i bait doesn't go any lower than
seven they're still gonna be ranked in
the top seven but i bet they're gonna
put them somewhere between five and
seven
you put tai to avos at four curtis
blades at three you got steep and cyril
gone there nabsi you have your your
champ up top who's figuring things out
with the the ufc brass and francis and
gano
so
you know a tie to a vasa francis fight
is fun as [ __ ]
um i don't know what they're doing with
stipe obviously the rumors are jon jones
stipe
um
it's a it's a bit of a problem for for
ty i guess he could wait it out you know
and get the winner of the next curtis
blades uh fight because curtis blades is
fighting soon
so
uh curtis blades
ties and entering fight
as far as those top guys go besides
cyril gone
i actually think tai matches up better
with francis
than he does anybody else
in the top five uh sarah gonz be a tough
night in the office for him the footwork
you don't play the the game the exchange
um
steve bad thing gets jon jones derek
lewis obviously what happened there
curtis blades or volkov you know i
depending what volkov we get
you know i just think
um
you know curtis blade's a tough night in
the office for for ty but he has a fight
so we don't have to worry about it right
now but it's all about matchups and you
know mitchell said it best you know we
go to heavyweight and i said in the
crazy he's going to jump up the you know
top five after beating the number three
guy
and matt goes you know it's better than
anybody when it comes to heavyweights
one through 15. it's all about styles
who lands first so he goes i never put
too much
weight into a guy being like 2 7 10 13.
anybody can beat any but if they land
first he's not lying
what's your point
um
as far as your mvp of that main event or
the main card it'd have to be tied to
avasa
catapult himself in the stardom
and i think more people i'm curious what
the pay-per-view numbers were but you
know thai two of us and he has his own
like chewy device now they selling he
had dana white do it with him which is
brilliant shuivasa which uh we need to
get one here big thai
um so shuivasa and the milk boys steve
will do it there you go that's the way
to do it
what shoe is that it's his own signature
oh it's like a it's like a model of a
shoe
i'll show you right now that's one of
the current events this right here
it's the right plastic thing that you
can put bottles in or cans in so it's
more like a sanitary kind of shoei dude
you know what with a lever you know uh
buy one right now chin i'll put it back
there i'll replace the yeezy and put tai
to
right there now buy one right now for me
get it set i'll have it in the cart
thank you sir i'll give you my info my
credit card when we need to after this
that'd be dope put the shoei back there
shout out to avaso hopefully they sell a
million of those at least
but that has to be your your mvp man has
to then bobby green i mean jesus christ
did he look good always fan of his and
then
andre arlovski what the [ __ ] that guy
still they keep giving these young
up-and-comers trying to get them out of
them the guy will not leave you know
what he is is he's will ferrell from
austin powers remember they keep trying
to kill me just won't leave
remember they put him down there and
he's like ah no no not fire and he just
he just can't kill him that's [ __ ]
androsky man
they keep tossing these young guys like
this guy to beat him he keeps [ __ ]
beating him
and you know he's not knocking him out
anything like that but he's just such a
vet
you know they don't these young guys
don't have the skill set of the
experience to beat him you know he won a
split decision so
um shout out to andre alaska man again
one of my favorite people to ever
compete i absolutely love andre alaska
training partner i'll say i fought him
might beat him not a big deal um but
they did give him the split decision in
vancouver which is a complete robbery
some people think of one of the worst
decisions of all time okay
it was actually a really boring fight
what can you do we're friends we train
together he knew exactly what i was
going to do i knew exactly what he was
going to do uh and i did take him down
so that's cool anyways um
[Music]
and then casey o'neil got it done she's
a little badass you're following the
women's flyweight division she's kind of
the next thing man she got done split
decision and rocktan uh mata fairy had
you know
it's uh that was her send-off
they gave her case o'neill in her
send-off fight and if you know anything
about fighting casey o'neill wasn't the
ideal matchup for your right off into
the sun retirement fight casey o'neal is
the next big thing in the women's
flyweight division she's a [ __ ]
savage so
[ __ ] cool enjoy your retirement with
this loss even those split decisions so
roxanne it's tough as they come man but
you ain't beating casey o'neil she's a
little beast
so yeah man that's it hope you guys
enjoyed the fights um
you know
i get it i get it as far as being upset
about the decision whenever there's a
fight of this magnitude and your guy
doesn't win
there's gonna be an uproar but
you're just yelling to the ether
nothing's gonna change so shut up you
know what i'm saying doesn't matter does
it is he won it's in the books it's in
the history books
it doesn't matter you on social media
doesn't matter
it's in the books it's over crowl you
want
it's just it's tough i i get it because
robert whittaker's such a [ __ ] nice
guy and his name's bobby knuckles
and he's fully redeemed himself and came
back after three wins and he thought he
was gonna get it done now i do agree
with
those are the two best middleweights on
the planet those are the two best
we've seen him fight twice now
i guess if robert whittaker wants to he
could you know work his way back up you
know to get a third shot after your 0-2
against the guy historically the ufc
really doesn't [ __ ] with that but they
might do it but it's a weird road for
robert whittaker and i gotta be honest i
don't think he ever beats izzy i think
izzy is one a and the rest of the people
are all the way down at a certain level
um
but robert wicker is the best
middleweight uh i would say he's the
best middleweight not named israel sonia
so what would i do if i'm robert robert
whitaker thank you guys for asking i
would like to tell you
well if you remember
robert whitaker used to fight at 170.
robert whittaker's not a big
middleweight uh that reach advantage
that izzy has is a huge issue for him if
you see robert whittaker um he missed a
million freaking punches
the the distance the reach is an issue
for him well it wouldn't be an issue at
um welterweight at 170. i think if he
could cut back down to 170 and i know
you know he's a better fighter at uh 85
but at this point his career you are
talking about a completely different
animal
a much better more skilled fighter uh so
really his iq is much higher too just
through experience and fighting the best
we have to offer at middleweight and he
was your middleweight champion so if you
can take that same swagger cut down to
70
kamaroso doesn't really have guys to
fight either
so you have a bit of a problem here
don't you
so um i if i'm busy from whittaker's
team
i'm looking at coming to 70 and doing a
super fight against kamar hussman
you look at the division at 170 again
for trying to sell pay-per-views here
and you're a businessman you own the ufc
i i would love izzy to go up to 205 if
yuri wins that makes sense and then also
robert whittaker um who's he gonna fight
again man who do you guys want to see
him fight i mean he's kind of been there
i don't know if you know he gets his
rocks off finding these guys who are
next in line so um why not cut to 70 why
not challenge and become another world
champion at welterweight against kumar
usman because kamar oozman vs whitaker
is a hell of a freaking matchup man it's
a hell of a match-up um
you know because again robert can
[ __ ] wrestle dude camaro can freaking
wrestle i'd say whitaker has more power
better footwork obviously stamina is not
an issue for him um i i think 170 at
whitaker makes a ton of sense you give
him
if i would just give him a straight
title shot you know being who he is and
the body of work he's done at
middleweight but if you want to give him
a warm-up go ahead and give him a
warm-up give him a jorgen mosby doll
give him a vicente lucay that'd be fun
you know give him a gilbert burns even
though you know i know gilbert's
fighting uh you know hamzap soon so
um but i'm just saying i'm listening off
the potential opponents he could fight
and he would probably beat so if you
want to give him a warm up at 70 see how
the cut goes he probably forgets how to
cut that weight let him do that and give
him a gilbert give him a sentence a
muhammad a hori maswa doll
you know him and stephen wonderboy
thompson obviously have a history wonder
why he beat him i think it was his last
fight at 170 the old memory bank serves
me right um michael chiesa
sean brady would be fun and neil magnu
would be fun that's if you want to give
him a warm up i don't think he needs it
i think his body would work at 85.
nobody's going to complain if you give
him a title shot at 170 especially
looking at the queue
you got to do it fairly soon because we
can only hold off hamzad so long
because the hamzah train is coming and
once he beats gilbert burns who's ranked
number two and i do think he beats him
and i hate that matchup for gilbert once
he does beat gilbert burns there he's
undeniable there's nothing else we can
[ __ ] do it's they seem to be the homs
out here
i'm not you know i'm not saying hamzap
beats usman right now
we're gonna find a
[ __ ] ton about hamzat when he fights you
know at the world championship level
when he fights gilbert burns now if he
starches gilbert burns if he molly wops
gilbert burns it's off to the [ __ ]
races
so we gotta get whitaker in there now
because that hamzah train is [ __ ]
coming and i don't listen maybe it's
just hype but it's proof is in the
pudding you look at his fights he's had
no issues what he did to jenga langer
with the [ __ ] name dude he beat the
[ __ ] out of him and according to his
camp people i very respect have all the
respect for in the world according to
alexander gus finn
we haven't seen the [ __ ] this is just
the tip of the iceberg of how talented
hamzad is and that's [ __ ] scary so
i'm robert whittaker's team let's go and
get in the queue right now let's go and
get that cue right now and fight for the
title right now and then if the hamzot
train does come and you have to defend
your belt if you do beat camaro great
but um that hums out trains coming so we
get moving man you don't want to wait
and have to fight that [ __ ] demon you
just don't nobody wants to fight hamza i
don't think camaro does
and and you know the thing is is if i'm
ranked you know top 10 i'm saying this
i'm leaning on the rankings going he's
eleven i'm not fighting him but we all
know why you're not fighting him the
hamza train's [ __ ] coming it's
undeniable it's scary and we're getting
a lot of questions answered very soon
when he fights gilbert burns and i have
a
good idea that that's not going to go
great for gilbert burns i'm up dude when
i say i'm on hamza and you know it's not
so hairy when i say i'm on his nuts you
think hamzad's using manscape.com promo
code cfc for 20 off not a chance he
keeps it hairy he keeps the hair like
his chest dog
so that harms that train's coming so if
i'm whittaker's team
it's time to move
that hums that train's coming man and i
don't see anybody beating him
i'm not i'm not saying steam rolls
through camaro right now but with
camaro's injuries
i don't know how much camaro has you
know what i'm saying i i don't know
i don't know
i know hamza obviously had the kovitch
[ __ ] but other than that
i don't know who beats him
i don't i i'm looking i'm licking the
rating rankings right now
ah
he'd be favored over everybody that's
what's scary
i know you love them too jen yeah now i
do
i didn't believe it at first well i
didn't know i needed more proof but that
legion length fight dude that was just
insane you're just molly wops dudes
talked
they're nuts it's [ __ ] we haven't
seen someone like this in a very very
long time this
dominant you know you're looking very
cabish but he has more power in his
hands and he's exciting and he's gonna
be sometimes not that exciting but oh
yeah yeah and his mentality scary [ __ ]
so again if i'm robert wicker's team and
you know we we have a inclination we can
make 70 and fight camaro which would be
a huge fight camaro's the the number one
pound-for-pound fighter on the roster
and he's looking for a you know a form
little flow
robert wicker's not a bad one it's a
huge name he's a huge draw you know
and again from camaro's team from izzy's
team
robert whittaker's team we're looking
how to make big bucks how to get these
pay-per-views all those make sense
because if we stay in our current
division
and we just keep beating these guys that
we've beat and there's no new blood
i don't know what it does for you i know
it sets records and contractually you're
going to get your pay and stuff like
that but
to get to that
[ __ ] you money which only a handful of
guys ever got in the ufc these are the
necessary steps and that's why i want
this for these guys
but i would bet my bottom [ __ ] dollar
that hamzat is gonna be running that
[ __ ] division for quite some time
could be off
i'm telling you man that guy's [ __ ]
scary
so if i'm robert we're getting over
there like now
let him fight i'm telling you dude they
give him gilbert there's nowhere else
for him to go
there's nowhere else to go
and
you know he could do camaro colby again
okay
for a third time okay
all right i guess we'll do that again
but as far as like getting our money
something fresh something new
robert work makes sense
homs it's just a matter of time hanzo
beats the number two guy then if he just
mops the floor with him
ufc has been looking for something like
this since conor
to me he's scarier man
he's way scarier yeah
just his mentality like oh
this guy was born to [ __ ] fight
and then out listen alexander's team out
there in sweden that he trains with and
when gustin goes i'm telling you dude
you should see this guy in practice his
coaches told me i'm you haven't seen
[ __ ] man i'm ted
you haven't seen anything like what he's
doing to people this is nothing this
guy's good everywhere we've never seen
him lose around in practice we toss them
in there against
everybody am i gonna call guys out but
you look at the names of that camp
bigger bigger guys bigger divisions
world-class strikers former world
champions monsters
again never lost around according to
this team in practice
we haven't seen [ __ ] and remember you
hear this and listen if he was just some
podunk team like okay who gives a [ __ ]
but when you're talking about that team
out in sweden if you remember we heard
the same stories about ak with khabib
like when it when dc and josh thompson
and josh johnson's the captain of ak
he's like oh dude i'm you haven't seen
[ __ ]
he
and uh josh thompson and dc say the same
thing about uh homeboy
um
khabib's best friend he grew up with oh
islam islam
same thing
now they're saying with makachev that
you haven't seen his full potential
because he uh isn't used to the bright
lights yet he needs more experience
the lights can't get bright enough from
hamza that's what's [ __ ] scary they
keep trying to scare this kid and
nothing's he's a goddamn serial killer
he's a sociopath good luck dude good
luck
make the lights as bright as you want
put him as his main event this kid
doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of that he
stays hairy stays trained you know what
i'm saying yeah
that's it man
well even though remember jack herman
just lost to sean strickland he's a 185
he they did that one-off wrestling match
together with hamza he said he's never
he couldn't believe the strength of
hamza like that's how crazy strong is ah
i love this [ __ ] man i love when a guy's
this when you have an outlier amongst
outliers you know what i'm saying like
hermansen's a [ __ ] outlet that guy's
a savage
the joker he's no punk and when he goes
dude
this dude's out of control yeah like
really i love this stuff the outliers of
all outliers
comes out unimpressed with israel
assange ufc 270 easy money
so this is what he wrote
um stop at her easy money for me zero
wrestling one round i'm gonna kill him
yeah
notice how you use the words kill him
and then uh what is he saying wait for
you real quick oh wow he just was like
izzy's come back yeah
as far as the mic goes do you see izzy's
valentine post to john jones
said you like uh fresh meat uh another
fighter not in your division named hamza
has been tweeting at you this fight has
he he said he hasn't played for me zero
wrestling one rounds i'm gonna kill him
okay
is he just
that's a dope response yeah if i'm busy
too it's like yeah i just wanna just
defend my world championship man i don't
this guy's he again we can only like and
again i love izzy and izzy hums out the
different store i'm not gonna get into
that but
these top dogs
they can do that right now
right now
hamzad's 11 hasn't had like a huge win
over a big time fighter yet but i'm
telling you man when that gilbert burns
fight goes down and he starches gilbert
burns then these guys are going to be
forced
to engage with hamza and it's off to the
races he's a huge [ __ ] star huge star
my boy mike the head of thick boy uh
productions he collects cards he's a
nerd he collects cards he has that
hamzat card and i think he's that rookie
card it's worth like [ __ ] eight grand
what
he's like we gotta get homs out on a
food truck and then sign my card
that'd be dope who came on food truck i
don't know think about hamza you don't
see him a lot of yeah he's not i don't
if he's out of here dude
whatever whatever it takes to get him
here i'm down and he speaks just enough
english where he can do it oh dude hey i
don't even [ __ ] about his english i'm
i'm sure it's
you know worthy i'm sure it's decent but
you know we've had guys that don't speak
english before it's
a tough go with their english and that's
fine but with him it's just scared yeah
and that's what i want scary even his
little lip thing little scar there that
just adds so much more like scary he
looks like the [ __ ] serial killer of
hannibal
if you remember oh yeah the red dragon
part three
he's that guy
now here's izzy this is such a crazy
post dude dude so
john is my age right
i fancy myself pretty good social media
you know i i post in ghost i'm one of
the best to do it posting ghosts i see
nothing of your opinions for a reason
um
but same with like when dana was going
with jake paul
listen man and izzy's fa you know
he's a social media master and you know
here's his youtube page which he [ __ ]
crushes and you know he's in the animes
in the social media and he'll run with
these memes and it's what they do
if you're if if you're above 35 36 if
you're above the age of 36
you just can't get you just can't engage
with these young kids and their social
media skills you know it's kind of like
baseball there's there's rules in
baseball
that we all know this it's unspoken of
but you know the rules you don't show
boat you don't do stuff like that
and a lot of fighters you know there's
unspoken rules
and these young kids dude
they're vaping they're [ __ ] watching
euphoria you know what i'm saying my
class can we can't run saved by the bell
i've a whole bit of it a bit on it in my
act but it's like we came up on saved by
the bell man
you know the biggest problem was jesse
taking caffeine pills these younger kids
you know we knew we knew you know the
the
mr spelding and they talked about their
homework and you would see them study
for tests and euphoria you ever seen
anybody in class ever
name one teacher they're just [ __ ]
and smoking and
tying needles and doing drug deals and
driving drunk and insane [ __ ]
the point is
is there's no filter with these young
kids and on social media they don't
abide by the same rules that the respect
we grew up on you know if you look at
[ __ ] talking you know even five years
ago we've really kind of kind of kicked
the trend off but
let's say eight years ago [ __ ] talking
between guys is we kept it inside the
ring inside the octagon
these young kids man there is no filter
so when dana want to talk [ __ ] up to
jake paul i'm like oh dude and then
again
i told you guys
when you find out what dana did you're
going to love me more like i do
but when you're doing the video you have
the dad angle and there's no graphics
it's not edited and you know he's just
speaking into it like okay and he's
calling jake paul out and jake paul's on
vacation
well the way it works same thing with me
i have a crew with me so if i need to
put some out my team will edit get
graphics we have [ __ ] subtitles so
you know exactly what's going on and
jake paul is thirty thousand times under
me at this [ __ ]
so he sees that shitty video from dana
talking all the [ __ ]
yeah you put your you put your toe in
the wrong pool man and you're gonna get
you're not gonna win that war and then
the kid has all the money in the world
and then makes a legit rap video and
hires actors that look like you write
the [ __ ] verse just talking [ __ ]
it's the same thing with jon jones he's
my age man
granted he's the goat and he won't talk
[ __ ] to guys and but the problem is
john's not fighting as he is and then is
he's younger and he fancies himself a
social media wizard
you talk [ __ ] you go bad on izzy he's
like an elephant and forget
this valentine's day post is
is so disrespectful it's hilarious
and all his fear and love and war
they're not even at war i don't know if
these guys ever fight each other now if
if going back to what i said earlier is
he does beat yuri if he gets the title
and yuri versus he makes sense and as he
were to beat yuri
then i think this strikes back up but
all the animosity john's gonna happen i
mean dude it says for those of you
listening it's a post from izzy this is
this is february 3rd
6 14 p.m at night all right 13th what
13th february 13th
at 6 14 p.m at night
people are having dinner
it's this is family dinner time
but you want to [ __ ] with these young
bucks this is what you get y'all
he put this is at stauben benefit happy
valentine's day now remember john has a
fiancee kids probably you know went out
and bought i don't know gucci perch some
[ __ ] for his girl and flowers and [ __ ]
and then decided to get on his phone
and then you get this from a guy that
just won the biggest fight of his life
happy valentine's day heart emoji heart
emoji it's the thought that counts exo
like that's nice of him
and then it shows a gentleman that looks
like jon jones wrapping his hands and
says jon jones wrapping a valentine's
day gift for his fiancee and this is
after the guy's accused of domestic
violence against his wife
welcome to the [ __ ] show
come on down
it's just like the savage post dude
savage
this can't be fun
and then jon jones just giving these
young bucks all the material in the
world you know he's making it easy for
him to fire off this [ __ ] it can't i
don't know why they play this game
i i would just keep it within the
confines of fighting you don't you don't
want to go personal these guys go
personal yeah think about the [ __ ]
jake paul talk hookers and sex tapes and
like all dana's dirt these kids don't
give a [ __ ] dude
again they're watching euphoria they're
sucking each other off there's math
there's [ __ ] heroin they're making
drug deals
you know
what else you got do you think okay
since jon jones and israel they're both
professionals right
if they see each other in the street do
you think it goes down
i think
izzy would be on guard you know i'm
saying
and i do think that when you go this
personal
i truly believe this
i i think if you can go this personal
this goes for any field fighting
football comedy podcasting
real estate agent whatever it is if
you're gonna go personal when you see
that person you gotta keep that same
energy and if a fisticuff happens to
break out you should expect that because
if you're gonna go this hard on
somebody's personal life
to me that's
i get it i enjoy it i'm here for the
[ __ ] show but if this was me and someone
did that to me when i see you it's not
all good yeah
we're not professionals you've crossed
the line
and i'm and i'm you know i'm going to
say something i'm probably going to hit
you like this isn't all good like you
look at like a diaz brothers look up
from the same cloth you better keep that
same energy man you talk [ __ ] about them
you know they're fires fighters fighters
they're no one's more hardcore than them
you see them whether they're retired
we're there and fought in ten years five
years whether they just fought you see
them you better keep that same [ __ ] you
better be on guard man you better keep
that same energy
so i i do think that's where
there's a little bit of a disassociation
with the younger
crowd that wants to do this social media
stuff and they want to clown these guys
on social media if you [ __ ] with the
wrong guy and
john's the wrong guy to [ __ ] pick him
you're when you see him you have to keep
the same energy it's gonna be a tough
night in the office for you on the
street too it's it's same with like
jakeland the hard way right because
in his world you know him and his
brother were flying in for the press
conference with showtime this i know
this right so at the time i worked the
fight i was working for showtime and a
month prior they're flying to i think
florida miami to do the press conference
and jake and logan came in on a
helicopter
baller move again as [ __ ] kids man
heroin euphoria dope and smoking sucking
dip and drink and you know they're wild
man and they're gonna do whatever it
takes to get likes and views and go
viral
by any means necessary that's why
they're so famous
and jake learned that
yes you're in social media and you're a
youtube star but when you cross into the
fight world remember these guys
especially a guy like floyd mayweather
came from the gutters man and if you
disrespect the certain guy in that in
this business there's gonna be
repercussions so when they're flying a
helicopter go to the press conference
jake paul tells logan
even before all the [ __ ] talk all that
stuff i'm gonna take uh floyd's hat and
loan goes i feel like it's a bad idea
logan's older he's been around a little
longer because i feel like it's a bad
idea and he goes i wouldn't do that and
jake goes now i'm going to do that and
logan was i wouldn't do that man
they go through the press conference to
talk all that [ __ ] jake makes about him
he's talking [ __ ] about his shoes
because they're untied which is kind of
kitty to me but whatever she's trying to
poke the bear
and then they get face to face and
floyd's like i'll be bolting the same
night which he would i'll be both in the
same night whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do
and all that's fine i'll beat you in the
ring the same night you know floyd's
[ __ ] 44 years old
you're not from this world
this youtube you know
euphoria world so
jake takes floyd mayweather's hat
he rips his hat off
and i think
in his head he's like oh this would go
viral it's gonna be funny oh got your
hat and where jake grabbed goes got your
hat
again floyd doesn't he's not cut from
this cloth where you do this [ __ ] just
to sell the fight he finds it very
disrespectful and i'm sure john does too
then the diaz brothers do too i'm sure
if he does to francis or
yuri or you know some of these other
guys you're gonna be in trouble man
um
even though hamza is younger you do that
to him he's gonna [ __ ] rip your face
off
so for jake i think he had a
fast pass on into the fight world where
these guys don't subscribe to your
youtube do it to go viral do it for the
views and he got straight beat up
beat up like floyd's team was like
what and then jumped him and beat the
[ __ ] out of him
and floyd's landing punches i think
jake's like holy jesus dude this is good
for both of us
floyd's like no it's not we don't play
this game what you doing man
i'm 50-0 [ __ ] i'm one of the
greatest fighters to ever do it some say
the best ever do it you grab my hat
i don't give a [ __ ] about boxing i'm
gonna [ __ ] about commissions and
sanctions
we're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you man
so i i you know
john's more from my world where
i get it
there's marketing and selling the fight
and you're poking fun at guys but when
you go personal and you want to make it
personal again this is any field comedy
whatever it is you want to go personal
when i see you in that green room you
keep the same energy it's not all good i
don't do it for the views that clicks
the likes i'm not from that
culture that's not what we do man so
keep the same energy i'm sure izzy's
very aware of this and you know is he's
no punk you know but
these young guys they are gonna have to
answer for a lot of this [ __ ] that gets
some likes and clicks and stuff like
that you gotta keep the same energy and
i don't think society should be mad
because i feel
if you're gonna do this
and then izzy is at dinner and john's at
the same restaurant and then john walks
up to him and slaps him in the face
that's how it goes
there has to be some consequences
and
busy should be able to fire back and
there should be no lawsuits or anything
like that
because i do think when it comes to
baseball the unspoken rules
and fighting there's unspoken rules
where if there is an engagement like
that where someone's hit outside the
octagon you don't press charges man this
is this is this is the game you don't do
that [ __ ] [ __ ] this is the game it's
similar you know remember when conor
crossed the line against
khabib
khabib don't play these games khabib's
from [ __ ]
uh dagestan yeah
stuff he's barely posted when he does
it's whatever he's posting a little more
now i think he has some help whatever
but again
they were and logan paul there at the i
think catch my favorite rest on la i
hate the l.a like the hollywood scene
what celebrity eat there i don't give a
[ __ ] but as far as food goes and
environment
and date night spot there's none better
like the best steak the best sushi it's
fantastic expensive through a [ __ ]
roof
but celebrities want to go there because
good vibe it's right off of uh
um
it's down the kind of hollywood improv
area right
so
celebrity is going to gravitate towards
that it's in west hollywood
so celebrity's going to gravitate
towards that um
but they had conor mcgregor there at the
same time khabib there and apparently
the staff was stressed the [ __ ] out not
because of conor although
conor talk [ __ ] he'll back it up but
could be he again he doesn't subscribe
to this
liddy world of going viral and doing
youtube he's gonna [ __ ] you up man
you've talked [ __ ] about dagestan and
remember his dad and stuff like that
again and and conor knows this he's he's
not that young he knows by talking all
that [ __ ] if they're in the same
vicinity in a mile radius you better be
on guard
i have no problem with that
i don't subscribe to it either if you go
personal again you got to keep that same
energy if you're gonna disrespect guys
family or heritage or country
family it's on dude you got it this is
goes beyond fighting because as much as
these guys are professionally get paid
to fight
these guys
you know the reason why they're
successful fighters is they're [ __ ]
savages man and if you're gonna
disrespect the savage and outlier
in in on the streets you better be ready
to go and that's how it should go
yeah connor threw the dolly at him you
know they're doing all that [ __ ] man
you know and think about hump the story
of hamza he's you know he's from that
part of the world even though he's in
sweden he was two and all he was a
nobody and because this is how much of a
[ __ ] savage hamzad is he's 2-0
outside he's nobody
he bought a [ __ ] ticket
from sweden to dublin and was gonna walk
into the [ __ ] lines then and find
connor and [ __ ] them up
and they got word of it and stopped them
at the airport
to contain them for a day and send it
back to sweden but if they didn't stop
him
again hampstead's not on instagram like
all right we'll see connor no no no no
no you you're talking about real [ __ ]
g's here man that's not those are the
problems you don't want to
i don't i don't get it
but and i think it goes for anybody if
it's a hater if it's you know a youtuber
talking [ __ ]
you can do that you can criticize
my comedy
my podcasting skills whatever but if you
go personal and i see you in the street
well well there's gonna be repercussions
that's the way the world should work you
just can't fire off at the mouth and not
expect consequences
that's how it should work when you're
dealing with outliers that's how it
should work
i agree though
they all it's such a meat head angle no
it's not
it's the non-bitch angle
it's the non-bitchy society's too soft
man there has to be repercussions for
your actions
and you're talking about the
best fighters in the world and you're
disrespecting making it personal
i don't
i don't [ __ ] with that never have
again you want to do it
i don't give a [ __ ] what your profession
is if you're gonna talk [ __ ] whether
it's a fighter football player
comic podcast or whatever it is
on the streets man you go personal
there's gonna be repercussions and i'm
not gonna have my brother film or
nothing like that you're gonna know
that's the way it should go
in all fields of life everything
if you work at a uh if you're doing if
you work at starbucks
in calabasas and the guy in starbucks
and one hill is talking all [ __ ] about
your family
and one day you go in there to get your
[ __ ] venti coffee your dark roast
coffee he's making coffee it's not all
good dude there you are i don't give a
[ __ ] what field you're in it ain't all
good
now you have to back up all that [ __ ]
you're talking man
oh and you're gonna physically hurt each
other yeah dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
because we're human beings
that's what we are you wanna talk all
that [ __ ]
you gotta you gotta be one to back it up
man that's that's the energy that's
where i come from
same thing you know if you're if you're
driving you know people have road rage
and the guy wants you know your family
with your kid and the guy's trying to
make you crash and stuff
again that's why i [ __ ] with sean
strickland so much when he had that road
rage incident you know
you're dealing with an outlier you never
know who you're [ __ ] with man but you
got to pay for your you know for your
actions so that guy's [ __ ] with sean
strickland one of the best men on the
planet who's
you know someone say psychopath you know
what i'm saying like
that boy is crazy yeah you're gonna cut
him off stuff like that and then he
pulls over and he's like cool dude
let's do it old school no guns no knives
and what's what what's that guy do
pulls out a gun oh i think he showed him
his like
holes he did something shriek was like
yeah [ __ ] that yeah well good but there
should like i'm cool
i'm old school man i'm my favorite show
is [ __ ] yellowstone 1883. i'm fine
where if there's a conflict and you're
talking all this [ __ ] and you want to
settle it
i don't want anybody you know
being you know hitting their head on the
cement or something like that or getting
their face bastion i'm not talking about
any of that
but if you want to hand it like men like
it's old school
go at it man there should be no charges
pressed nothing
i think the world be a little tight
button up a little tighter if we moved
like that people wouldn't be so free so
easy to fire off a tweet or talk [ __ ] or
re you know throw out a youtube comment
because if
on instagram if you're a hater and they
what they should do is go put in your
home address or work address
so when you post we know exactly where
you are but they don't do that do they
they hot behind there
there's a reason for that
because if if because you wouldn't talk
like that to that person in real life
guarantee what
but if you did and you're about that
life cool me too man i'm about that life
of a set of skills that go pretty well
with it
so i'm down dude
but again that's
oh aggressive bro culture
all right
speaking my truth is disrespect and by
the way at the very least they could do
is unprivate their accounts i hate when
people talk smack and have a private
account or they have like two followers
because you know they made an account
talk [ __ ] but that's why but that's why
they do it and i know i'm saying you
know what i'm saying like you gotta hide
behind this thing because i know because
if you were at say [ __ ] applebee's
with your girl someone's talking [ __ ]
about chin maybe the audio is [ __ ] up
maybe something happened applebee's yeah
you're happy with your girl you know
full rack of ribs she has the [ __ ]
awesome blossom whatever it is
and that's that same guy wouldn't go up
to you and go hey chin your [ __ ] that
audio [ __ ] suck dude i wouldn't mind
that if you talk [ __ ] about my girl or
me then then i'd be like get the [ __ ] at
her we would have to fight but i i would
at least respect him more if that guy
who talked [ __ ] to you saw you in person
and was like hey chin
you did that guy talking that was me
dude i [ __ ] hate daddy on that one
show you [ __ ] it up for me dude yeah
cool man let's talk about it yeah and
then if we can't figure out through
words then we can do whatever you want
whatever you want if you feel that
strong about it let me know how it goes
for you at an applebee's too yup shout
out to applebee's are they still around
i see them around
yeah i just look like applebee's your
friday night hang or whatever the [ __ ]
it was that was like the slogan i don't
think it's the pandemic they had to
chill out on that friday night hanging
thing right i don't know what they're
doing
i'll tell you i've been doing a lot
lately i know we are going to stop
firing the kid i started late because
i'm hungover but um
i've been on because i'm still on
carnivore didn't cheat yesterday even
though they had the most ridiculous
sushi at this place didn't cheat
i was [ __ ]
uber eating [ __ ] damn gourmet his
team was there they kept him because i
was on the outside he was the host i had
to see everybody
so they couldn't hand the food to dc
this [ __ ] dude ate non i mean i'm
handing burgers steak
chicken
snacks
tater tots drink i'm like bro
he's like you don't mind like i don't
care dude i'm handing you all the food i
was just uber eats
but so being on this car the point of
being on this carnivore diet
i've really relied on outback steakhouse
because you know you don't want to order
from [ __ ] del frisco's every night
you don't be that stupid with your money
you know don't fish like a hundred
[ __ ] dollars in postmates but outback
you get their top sirloin cut
it's like 30 bucks can be the great be
best beef in the world for you but [ __ ]
dude i just get a giant either like the
prime rib or i'll get the rib eye or the
the top swirling cut it's like 14 ounces
that's all i eat
shout out to outback man sounds good
ribeye i don't know i'm not red bite
that they actually have prime rib yeah i
would love to get rib they i ordered the
prime rib uh like two weeks ago and they
forgot the horseradish
the only reason you get it
it's so frustrating there's nothing you
can do yeah you just gotta take it
so we don't really have time that much
time for current events right uh give me
like the two best okay this i thought
was awesome because i just saw this oh
wait let's go here remember you said
you showed him the shoes right i want to
give them a shoe that represents them so
i came up with this idea i'm like can
you find can you source this shoe
so these are the shoes i select how are
you john at wow strong move alvins
[Music]
yes and to me these represent you
because you got to be the most unique
guy in the ufc so these jordan ones
represent you my bro [ __ ] [ __ ] holy i
don't i don't have myself i definitely
want to know these are the sickest
[ __ ] shoes i've ever seen he warmed
to the fights on saturday yeah no one
did a worm to the fight sportscenter
picked it up what they literally were
talking about his shoes here
holy sh
how dope is that wow
that's pretty dope
look at that
sorry espn of me i thought it was
sportscenter
uh
oh and steve center
so it says sugar shawn mma rolling up to
uc standing with the jay balvin once
yeah it's all about the shoes
you could have gave me a shout out i'm
the guy that sourced them i'm the guy
that [ __ ] got the shoes you could
have shouted out your boy come on you
spend more friends
i do a huge show for you guys equals
more pay-per-views help a brother out
but that was dope
yeah i'm gonna post them like do you
wonder where he got him with a face like
this
uh this is just an update on francis and
god on dana white they said that uh once
he comes back from cameroon and this is
marker on monday
they're gonna have a dinner and talk
so that's a good step in the direction
right yeah again i i in in a perfect
world i i think dana comes to agreement
with francis and they allow him to fight
tyson fury next you know and they they
come to agreement and you know he can
fight tyson fury and fight the winner of
john stephen
you know
it's best for for both
you know if france i would hate if
francis just bounced and was fighting
some other organization because i don't
see him
fight anywhere else
i don't so i pray to god they'd get that
deal done
you want some more
uh is there one is there a really good
one i'm missing anything or people like
how do you not talk about that kid well
i mean and then you're gonna be at
applebee's and guys [ __ ] you
you mentioned jake paul and you already
talked about the joe rogan situation
quite a bit but so there's jake paul
uh posting about this on social media
because he sticks up for guys i love
izzy's take on rogan too yeah i had that
lined up as well but i love it oh did
did izzy give rogan a shout out after he
won i don't remember that part okay but
the press conference the press i'll just
play out first real quick
i get a piece over there what what's the
advice would you give
you around uh joe rogan there's been a
lot of controversy
there's a lot of [ __ ] in this game
there's a lot of snakes in this game
i've been in this fight game since 2008
and joe rogan is one of the nicest
coolest
humble [ __ ] i've had the
pleasure of working with understand that
you know it's just
[ __ ] the noise man you know what they're
trying to do you can't control the man
and he's got the biggest platform
in the world right now so that's my
[ __ ] rogan [ __ ] the noise
[Applause]
i [ __ ] love izzy man that's the name
facts that was dope
god damn i love izzy just won't get any
cooler
and then jake paul says so espn disney
poll joe rogan from the ufc broadcast
but stand behind dana white who calls
reporters douchebag says female fighters
look like male fighters and dressed in
heels claims brain damage is part of the
gig you pulled the wrong guy mr shipak
so he shouldn't have gone off on dana
white because you know
all that stuff happened but not my again
not my story to tell but when it comes
out which i would you know it's hard to
keep anything secret these days when it
comes out what exactly went down with
rogan not working the pay-per-view you
guys will love rogan more and you will
love dana white even more
so
i love jake paul and i love that he's
you know fighting for the fighters pay
and all that stuff and what's right and
you know obviously dana wants to engage
in the [ __ ] talk so jake paul's never
gonna stop talking [ __ ] but
he's gonna have to
again this is his attempt to go after
dana but this isn't a this isn't a dana
thing yeah i'm telling when the news
comes out you're gonna realize
dana is a [ __ ] gangster he really is
man in the in the in people that rally
behind their friends and don't
you know scramble like roaches when the
lights on on your friend it means the
world to me and and dana's that guy who
sticks behind his guys so um again
you'll never hear me talk to you about
dana again after i heard what he did and
um you know i i i like that jake paul's
defending rogan absolutely love that i
love even more what izzy said because
that's what we need more people speak
out and there's nothing better so
shout out to both of them jake paul
don't mind the message i think his
energy is still on you know going at
dana the message overall is cool but
dana's not the enemy here
dana's not the enemy at all
co
is that it so we have two fights coming
up okay this one's uh pissed my pants so
it'll be cool on air you want to go
first or just cover these now let me
cover this okay so this is a fight night
it was supposed to be um rafael
dossano's in physique but physique had
visa issues so they're gonna push that
one back so now the new headliners
walker johnny walker versus jamal hill i
mess with it yeah it's a fun one
ooh joaquin buckley
alison's a fantastic fight
parker porter is fun um
yeah
jessica rose clark's always great
you know this isn't going to blow your
[ __ ] hair back but uh johnny walker
jamal hill you know johnny walker since
he said do the worm and blows goddamn
shoulder out he's never been the same
but this is an exciting fight
uh this is saturday night yeah honey
span yeah i'm gonna watch the [ __ ] out
of this i'll take it that's a fun fight
card oh yeah you finally because bang
bro lane versus mike perry yeah enjoy
that lane
enjoy that lane sick tats i'll give you
that and he shredded and then you also
got uh chad mendes versus fame as
remember yep famous our favorite uh
musician in the game
so enjoy those that's saturday night
yeah from 19th that's saturday night
brought to you by on it as well bkfc
that's saturday night that's a great
card i will actually watch that card
i love it mendez yeah that's a tough
fight for our boy alvarez so chad man is
a savage yeah is that it that's it all
right kids uh enjoy those fights um
you know for me uh back on the road they
did uh release the the mass mandate
shout out to california la said we're
not gonna go by that so you guys keep
your mask on but everywhere else you're
good
cool i'm in sacramento uh the capital of
california northern california
and that is sacramento uh february 24-26
so there's one show thursday two shows
friday two shows saturday it's the punch
line that [ __ ] will sell out i
guarantee it so get tickets right now
while you're listing this your tickets
at thickboy.com or fatkz.com
and before that uh it's shaban friends
at the hollywood improv one night only 8
p.m
it's gonna be our fifth freaking sellout
it's me and very special guests it's my
favorite shows to do i absolutely love
them it's the hollywood improv shout out
to the improv hollywood improv los
angeles california one show one night
only february 23rd 8 p.m shop and
friends you know who i roll with it's
gonna be a monster of a show we have
another very special guest last special
guest that so the last show oh he asked
glad yes we had jeff dye brian cowan
chappelle lacy crystal ill myself
and
aziz
uh
and yeah
so you know we have some pretty good
special guests we have another big
special guest february 23rd 8pm
hollywood improv let's sell that [ __ ]
out make it the fifth sellout in a row
and then sacramento you're coming up
punchline sacramento it's not a huge
room that [ __ ] will sell out so you get
tickets right now because i can't add
shows that's february 24th through 26th
then just announced as well as nashville
tennessee zany's one of my favorite
freaking clubs in the world that's march
10th through the 12th and the chicago's
end of march march 24th 26th come get
some chicago
so uh yeah la hollywood improv february
23rd sacramento you're next on thick boy
tour the 24-26
tickets at thickboy.com or f-a-t-k-z.com
also next week we're finally dropping
the oops grenade calabasas fight
companion tees hoodies and hats that's
on thickboy.com as well i'll keep you
posted just follow me on social media to
see when the what time those drop i
think it's on tuesday but the oops bomb
uh shirt they see me rocking all the
time we have hats hoodies and tees
dropping and it's the first cfc uh merch
that we're dropping so that should be
dope man but uh that's it kids
thanks for watching thanks for listening
like subscribe uh thick boy uh youtube i
told you man
the team is working the team is working
dude are we ever and i think we're at
126 000 subscribers it's basically a
month old since we changed everything
from showtime over to thick boy and
we're doing the goddamn thing man so i
can't thank you guys enough the next
thick mudder is april 9th and what's
going to be dope about that and i'll
blast this out because i don't think
they've made it available yet to the
public
but if you're worried about running the
15k and i get the beast so now for the
thick boy uh
thick mudder you can run the 5k the 10k
or the 15k i do the 15k because i'm
psychopath probably should be doing the
five if i do the 15k so now you'll be
able to run with me but you can do the 5
10 or 15k race all right casey's gonna
do it again because he's a savage we
have everyone in here do it with us all
right the whole team's doing shin's
going to fix his neck to the 5k so
that's cool
uh but keep post on that post on my
social media and that's april 9th in san
bernardino san bernardino is that right
san bernardino uh that's right outside
la way closer than lake uh
whatever the hell it was elsinore that
was so far away but this is actually
right outside la so uh come get some man
5k anybody listen i prom listen to me
right now i guarantee no matter what
shape you're in you can do the 5k the
10k for sure and the 15k even again no
matter what shape you're in we've had
some big boys big girls small girls
small boys thick boys thick girls
everyone finished the 15k it's the
funnest experience you're ever gonna
have on there the crews there with
special merch for you guys it's such a
fun time i'm telling you it's a great
experience and now not only i can do the
thick mudder but remember last time we
used the thick code
it just got you into my group and we did
the meet and greet and we got to eat
together after the race but now they're
going to give you guys a discount so i
can't offer a code and not offer a
discount so now uh tough mudder was like
oh are bad so for this next one i'm
gonna
make sure you guys get a discount all
right um that's it sacramento europe
february 24th to 26th at the punch line
uh stay fixed stay safe thanks for
watching like subscribe tune into the
thick boy channel i have so much
freaking content dropping it's unreal
and i love you guys man and i will see
you around the way i'm out
you